اذا بهرجه واحتفالات صاخبه امتدت لساعات
امتزجت فيها العراقه والتقاليد القديمه
باللمسات الحديثه الحفل التتويجي
والتاريخي اول ملك بريطاني جديد منذ 70
عاما انتهى فيما المهرجانات الشعبيه
متواصله لكن هذا السغب تطخ عليه تحديات
كبيره تقع على عاتق الملك تشارلز الثالث
اولها انه لا يحظى بشعبيه كبيره بين
البريطانيين مقارنه بوالدته فنها يتمثل
باطاله عمر العائله المالكه فوفق احدى
استطلاعات الراي دعم الملكيه سجل ادنى
مستوياته منذ اكثر من 30 عاما 55 بالمئه
فقط من البريطانيين يرون ان بقاء النظام
الملكي مهم لحد كبير بينما ايد نحو 27%
الغاء النظام الملكي تماما ومن التحديات
الجاثمه امام تشارلز الثالث ضمان عدم
انهيار الكومنويل الذي يراسه وهو اتحاد
سياسي يضم 56 دوله حيث بدات دول بالاتحاد
مناقشه علاقتها بالتاج البريطاني على مدار
السنوات الماضيه والسعي للتحول الى
جمهوريات والانفصال عن نظام الملكي مثلا
جامايكا فالملك الجديد سيتوجب عليه كذلك
تحديث المملكه بما يتماشى مع العصر الجديد
وتحديد هويتها وعلاقتها باوروبا خصوصا بعد
خروجها من الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات